il est si beau l'enfant avec son doux
sourire sa douce bonne foi sa voix qui
veut tout dire c'est pleure vite apaiser
laissant
errer sa vue étonnée ravi offrant de
toutes parts sa jeune âme à la vie ainsi
Victor Hugo décrivait-il l'insouciance
mesdames et messieurs les députés c'est
insouciance que nous devons à nos
enfants car c'est dans un cocon
d'insouciance que nos enfants façonnent
leur âme d'hommes et de femmes libres de
citoyens éclairés de personnes capables
d'humanité d'émancipation de
spiritualité et de relations apaisées
aux autres et AEM à eux-mêmes et c'est
cette insouciance que nous devons à nos
enfants et que nous devons préserver par
tout moyen dans la société numérique car
si le numérique leur ouvre des
opportunités formidables d'échanges de
communication d'apprentissage nos
enfants sont victimes en ligne
d'atteindre brutale à leur innocence et
leur intimité exposition au contenu
pornographiques cyber-harcèlement
addiction aux réseaux sociaux tous les
enfants de France sont désormais
concernés je pourrais citer des chiffres
ils sont éloquents
je pourrais rappeler ici que l'épreuve
scientifiques de lien de causalité entre
l'utilisation débridée des réseaux
sociaux et la santé mentale des enfants
et adolescents s'accumulent mais je
crois qu'il est plus plus édifiant
encore d'écouter les enfants nos enfants
qui témoignent lorsque madame la
ministre voulait convier au Conseil des
ministres des enfants ou lorsqu'ils
participent aux réunions du Conseil
national de la refondation
nos enfants qui témoignent de leurs
sentiments d'avoir été précipités trop
tôt dans la jungle des réseaux sociaux
comme si on les avait poussés dans le
grand bain sans leur avoir préalablement
et patiemment appris à nager nos enfants
qui témoignent de leur colère à
l'endroit des grandes plateformes
déployant tous les moyens pour capter
leur attention au risque de les enfermer
dans des prisons algorithmiques de les
plonger dans des abîmes de tristesse et
de mal-être nos enfants qui témoignent
mesdames et messieurs et députés et qui
nous appellent à l'action et nous ne
pouvons rester sourds à cet appel nous
ne pouvons accepter le sacrifice d'une
génération sur l'Hôtel des géants du
numérique et nous avons d'ores et déjà
commencé à agir grâce aux travaux menés
par Bruno Studer la France sera bientôt
le premier pays du monde a généralisé le
contrôle parental par défaut sur tous
les appareils vendus sur son territoire
des smartphones aux consoles de jeux
vidéo en passant par les tablettes ce
contrôle parental restreindra l'accès
aussi très énervé aux adultes fera
respecter les limites d'âge des réseaux
sociaux et permettra aux parents de
contrôler le temps passé sur l'écran à
cause du déferlement massif de contenu
pornographique en libre accès sur
Internet 2 millions d'enfants sont
exposés chaque mois à des contenus
pornographiques c'est un scandale
révoltant il réside dans le fait que les
sites concernés ne vérifient pas
sérieusement l'âge des utilisateurs nous
avons pris une loi en 2020 qui les
contraint à le faire sous peine de voir
leur diffusion bloqué par le juge nous
exigeons qu'il s'y conforme désormais
mais les violences faites aux enfants en
ligne ne s'arrêtent pas au porno Un
million d’élèves sont victimes de
cyber-harcèlement chaque année en France
là aussi nous agissons avec PAP and Guy
nous avons lancé cette année
l'expérimentation du passeport internet
qui sera généralisé à la rentrée
prochaine désormais tous les élèves de
6e dans notre pays bénéficieront d'un
module de sensibilisation au risque et
aux attitudes à adopter lorsque l'on est
victime ou témoin de cyber-harcèlement
et je veux en particulier saluer
l'action du 30 18 dont nous avons
annoncé récemment avec Charlotte COBAL
le renforcement des effectifs et
l'extension des heures d'écoute mais
face à cette vague d'insécurité
numérique la meilleure des digues c'est
la protection parentale c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons lancé il y a
quelques semaines une vaste campagne de
communication sur le site je protège mon
enfant gouv.fr qui contient toutes les
informations utiles et tous les outils
pour les parents nous avons commencé à
agir au niveau français je le disais
nous avons également agi au niveau
européen sous l'impulsion du Président
de la République
et sous présidence française de l'Union
européenne l'Europe a fait un pas
historique dans la direction d'une
meilleure régulation des plateformes au
profit des mineurs avec le DSA le
Règlement sur les services numériques
avec ce règlement les plateformes de
réseaux sociaux entrent enfin dans l'air
de la responsabilité elles devront
satisfaire à nos exigences de modération
des contenus et elles devront faire la
transparence sur leurs algorithmes et
leurs données et de nouvelles
obligations s'imposeront à elle pour la
protection des mineurs elles devront
proposer des conditions générales
d'utilisation qui sont facilement
compréhensibles pour les enfants elles
devront prendre les mesures toutes les
mesures pour assurer le plus haut niveau
de protection de la vie privée de la
sécurité et de la sûreté des mineurs et
ces mesures peuvent inclure en
particulier des interfaces adaptées et
l'adaptation de normes de protection des
mineurs à leurs services et puis enfin
elles auront l'interdiction de faire de
la publicité ciblée sur les mineurs
vous le voyez mesdames et messieurs les
députés nous avons commencé à agir mais
nous devons continuer c'est la raison
pour laquelle je salue la proposition de
loi déposée par le président Marc Angel
et le groupe horizon elle vient
s'attaquer à l'une des dimensions du
problème l'absence de vérification d'âge
pour l'inscription sur les réseaux
sociaux et l'absence de recueillement du
consentement parental pour les enfants
de moins de 15 ans ce que ce texte va
changer c'est que les grandes
plateformes de réseaux sociaux seront
tenues de faire respecter les limites
d'âge qu'elles se sont elles-mêmes
fixées et c'est qu'il ne sera tout
simplement plus possible pour un réseau
social d'inscrire un mineur de moins de
15 ans sans le consentement de ses
parents dans nos débats autour de cette
proposition bienvenue mesdames et
messieurs les députés il nous faudra
trouver le bon équilibre l'équilibre
entre la protection de nos enfants qui
est une priorité absolue et le
renforcement de l'autorité parentale si
nous exigeons des plateformes le plus
haut niveau de sécurité pour nos enfants
si nous exigeons d'elle qu'elle vérifie
l'âge des utilisateurs nous devons
préférer à l'interdiction pure et simple
d'accès aux réseaux sociaux un
renforcement de la capacité des parents
à contrôler cet accès à accompagner
leurs enfants dans le dialogue c'est cet
équilibre entre les règles fixées par la
loi et l'accompagnement dans le cas de
familial que je souhaite que nous
puissions trouver ensemble pour protéger
nos enfants et pour leur garantir le
droit à l'insouciance je vous remercie